to go and breath let his pair to pack
look at this this just came out it's the
Sun Lee parable demonstration short demo
if you rose remember I played a Sally
parable not too long ago it's probably
one of the most famous mods ever created
actually and now it's being made in a
standalone version stand alone ha ha ha
anyway they made a demo it just came out
I'm very curious about it I'm very
excited for the game
so without further ado let's begin the
demo if you hear oh hey guys if you hear
heavy breathing it's my dog he just
doesn't want to let me be alone today I
like the music that's one of the things
about the mod that was really great and
I'm glad they integrated it because
before he is like whatever hey cherry
your kind of random
what are you doing that I don't trust
you so if you don't know the other
better if you don't know Stanley parable
while you're about to know is 28 well no
[ __ ] [ __ ] late please enter the
demonstration room thank you and have a
pleasant demonstration thank you ok well
this game is pretty much mind [ __ ]
double mine [ __ ] in Section double
triple [ __ ] that's how much waiting room
please wait for your number and then
enter ok ok well I'm 28 right ok so the
thing is I can still go in or I could
wait so what should I do
I don't [ __ ] know how about this ball
that's not even a bowl should we wait
let's play the game by the rules right
now because I know you bros get piss if
I don't so 20 it's taking so long
come on
ah ah I bet it's gonna stop it like 27s
I should like that could it go any
slower it's like watching paint dry
ah there we go
famous demos Metal Gear Solid what the
[ __ ]
I like the wallpapers this game has
great wallpapers I given that what's
happening a lot areas come to the
Stanley parable live demonstration thank
you it will be my pleasure to guide you
through this sneak peek at what to
expect in the Stanley parable I miss you
just enough to leave you hungry for more
how exciting
God you just feel that nervous tension
the looming uncertainty why don't we
drink in the anticipation for a moment
okay twenty minutes or so
twenty minutes uh sounds twenty minutes
don't move or act in any way simply
remain motionless and let the thrill of
demoing the Stanley parable wash over
you pain buzzing wait for I get it
you're too anxious you can barely hold
still yeah I think we should walk off
that nervous energy before getting the
demo underway okay what do I do
take you on a little tour of the
facility Oh take a demonstration for a
game like the Stanley parable [ __ ] away
me now Fitness's where I and the other
Proctor's have been working meticulously
to construct a demo that explains
clearly and concisely exactly what the
Stanley parable is hazed and why you
should spend real-world money on the
main game
Rhian well money illustrations are
tricky and without the proper technology
you run the risk of the player having no
idea what to expect in the full version
ah here is one such technology these
buttons are meant to convey the meaning
of choice and the impact of the decision
okay choices carry tremendous meaning
and consequence didn't you know that at
your head yes I try picking one of these
buttons to press and we'll see what your
choice says about you how how is that
gonna Tao okay all right
let's let's actually give you some time
there's no way I can reach those there
is a way I can reach I can't jump so I
can jump off the ledge can i no all
right well I am gonna go for you how
fascinating here while you know that 94%
of all people who select that particular
button are sexual predators what our job
is really to illuminate the very
intangible nature of our minds and souls
it's not true I swear it's not sure okay
what else can I show you then this place
is the Buffalo of game design nothing is
wasted okay so I can go in wherever I
want let's start with a demo sadhas this
device tells you whether or not you're
inside a video game demonstration
somewhere around here there's also a
device that tells you whether or not
you're inside a device that tells you
whether or not you're inside a video
game demonstration maybe it's this
nothing in this room will kill you no
ding okay thanks are you that eager for
the demo to start don't worry we're
almost there
fine complement okay one of the most
important parts of administering any
demonstration is pumping up your ego and
appealing to insecurities about your
sense of self-worth that's why we use
this room to develop cheap compliments
to char on the player during the demo go
ahead and press that button to see some
of the superficial flattery we've been
cooking up yeah all right I'm curious
about this one My heavens I've never met
someone who can consume as much uranium
in a single sitting as you can just look
at you go how the [ __ ] is that a
compliment of all the people I know who
are playing this exact demo at this
exact moment and standing in this exact
room your performance is easily in the
top 5,000 come and go as far as 4600
okay yeah let's see oh this is
embarrassing I really can't think of
anything else to say I know you've
really exhausted my list of compliments
goodness that was fast either you or
this department has a lot of room for
improvement
okay then what's next really I thought
he was actually gonna compliment me well
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him that's what I what is
this a random chance that when a pet
shakhter [ __ ]
well it's Sunday right leg motion boosts
now here's what we use to convey story
these boom
convert text from a story into raw
emotion ahead step into one of them and
feel the sheer power of narrative
exposition discovery or despair which
one breast I'm waiting seriously that
what which one discovery despair
obviously where did this goose go these
cracks that we stood a pardon they
shielded us from us where did these
cliffs go these cracks that we stood
upon they shielded us from our own
ignorance they spoke coddling words and
wrapped our vulnerabilities in the
woolen cloth that so many times I tried
to set a flame if I knew these comforts
now would their fighters be any more
sick I have no idea what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
it was though and within the shame he
carried that ocean breeze did drift the
first okay jesus [ __ ] christ well is
there something behind here no now we
have to save at least a few emotions for
the full game ah come on
this game is unique to say the least
oh how vulnerable of you if at any point
during the demo you need to cry just let
me know and we can take a minute
such an [ __ ] he's way more sassier
than the last time do you like about
this room is perhaps the most important
Joel encounter in the demo this is where
we determine whether or not the demo has
been effective no doing you can't make
that decision err um play the demo we've
put so much work into this demonstration
would it be a shame if you rushed right
into making a purchasing decision
without seeing it first let this one
simmer you'll have plenty of time to
decide later fine
jeez wall technology you'll find this
exciting we've actually developed a wall
that you can walk through go ahead
that is exciting that is exciting Oh hmm
guess it's still in development right
okay moving along
god damn it is the anticipation still
feeling it I just fell butter that's
[ __ ] because you're a [ __ ] dick we
did the button when we did the button
one I think we did all of them unless
there's someone hiding that I don't know
about or that ain't didn't complete what
is that out of order
all right now I can go through no the
gate still looks like it's there what is
this a Nega you have it everything you
need to know about how video game demos
are made really are you sure it's still
important that we address safety
concerns please closely observe the
following possible negative side effects
of playing the Stanley parable if you
agree to be held 100% responsible for
any and all injury or long-term damage
no physical or otherwise Oh her while
playing the demo please do not press the
large red glowing disagree button at
this time nothing no objections you're
quite sure about there uh well alright
then wish my dad to experience one or
all of the previously listed symptoms
let's establish a signal for you to
convey to me that you wish the
demonstration to be terminated about
there see step into a dance perimeter
yeah please perform a dance your dance
has been recorded data the event that
you feel confused or disoriented by
anything you see excited a perform that
dance and I will terminate the demo
immediately right all preparations have
been made it is time at last are you
prepared for the scub
this is a trap this is another trap I
don't like this what the [ __ ] oh wait
what what Stanley parable demonstration
what your number is 29 when your number
is displayed please enter the
demonstration room 1 queue and have a
pleasant demonstration what bet okay uh
I'm lost
let's just get back to the green room
and start the demo again I must have
done something wrong the first verse she
said 29 but remember and okay what this
is seriously the coolest demo I have
ever played ago the Stanley parable demo
take to finding the demo learning
exactly what the Stanley parable is
haha
okay what is this what is this out
what's this I don't know
and it my supposed to click it ain't
uh-huh
very good eat wait wait wait wait what
it's this is all wrong this isn't the
Stanley parable this is a game where you
press a button and it says eight
continuously pressing the number eight I
can guarantee that this button does not
appear anywhere in the main game why is
it here instead of the demo for the
Stanley parable
was it a demo go I don't know Shaul demo
here before he something has gone it's
all gone horribly wrong we need to get
you out of here before you start forming
impressions of the stand these eight
guys we need to get up we need to start
over
you mustn't stay here another minute out
beats out hey I kind of like the eight
gaming's man this is better than call of
duty perhaps you misunderstood me so let
me reiterate as clearly as I can now
this is not the Stanley parable but it
says it as doing is pushing a button
over and over that doesn't nothing but
speak the word aids has that gotten you
into presses mops under the impression
you're playing the Stanley parable right
now an assumption that is I should
remind you again he's it entirely
erroneous but it's awesome eat eat eat
and whenever happens if I keep there in
a makes sense why would I have gone to
all of this elaborate setup just to
demonstrate a game that doesn't do a
single thing except repeat the word ate
the waiting room the green room a tour
of the facility all of that for no
reason are there until contextualize and
build up this particular game why what
about this game deserves any of that
time and attention are you seeing
something in it that I'm not I guess so
because eight is a pretty awesome number
you can like divided with two and it
becomes a four I need holy [ __ ]
you can only do that to a certain amount
of knock it out go no nevermind I'm
gonna keep it is the deal it isn't
possible that you still think this is
the Stanley parable
I've restated the fact too many times
but it said stoutly terral's that you
are now consciously choosing to delay
the actual demo as long as possible fine
oh goodness finally now let's get back
to business and start this demo over
from the top from the top
really what about it was a goal then the
door is closed what do you want from me
uh I'm going backwards I don't know bad
I favor like this uh uh foot it a what
what welcome to the solution
demonstration your number is 31 your
number what what okay now let's take a
minute to get something straight here
okay when you sit down to play this demo
you are assuming an amount of
responsibility for its outcome now I
can't say for certain with you causes to
encounter the eighth game rather than
the Stanley parable paid game with us
who t safe assumption that you had
something to do with it at this time
please take a minute to think about all
of the mistakes you made in playing this
demonstration as well as your lack of
respect for demo taking general what I
guess I should have clicked eight that
many times and I guess I could have
danced a little better and I vote for a
Baba I could really feel the
introspection on my end now that we're
all on the same page again I feel ready
to attempt the demonstration once more
but I was in a minute third attempt
we shall truly come to understand the
meaning of the Stanley parable let the
demonstration be
this is better be spectacular this is
all I'm saying
I love this game you just never know
what the [ __ ] to expect
it can't be over yet you didn't see
anything everything that was supposed to
demonstrate why the Stanley parable is a
quality experience worth your time and
money
Nate game was awesome I'm sure they
don't know no no no no we have to get
out of here we have to find something
for you to do anything the demo cannot
end like this
now hurry hurry this way are you sure
you're not gonna [ __ ] with me okay yes
this is new this is different
surely there must be a game somewhere in
here hey okay how about this cop yes
pick up the car okay I'm doing it
uh all right now I put it some and the
bin uh okay ah there you go Bob I did it
you won you know what you get for
winning an achievement Wow where a
parable Joseph based on what you played
so far would you purchase the Stanley
parable well you kind of a dick so I
don't know I don't get it it's pundit
what a clear and straightforward
demonstration of the merits of the
Stanley parable I am convinced of the
quality of the full game I think I get
available you really do get it you
understand oh I was so worried yep I
just wanted you to know what I see in
the Stanley parable what I think makes
it quelle special it's so very difficult
to put into words we'll all be on that
now aren't we
yeah sure we're wrong let's get to the
end and the final choice the final
choice ending ending where are you where
are you is is it
yes the end now this is where we want
the damage here
and I think it's time for you to log
your final decision as to whether or not
the Stanley parable is any good and it
all comes to this please consider very
carefully before answering much is at
stake and since it is such a unique
charming game even though it's being a
dick I think the answer is obvious it's
like working right now
are you sure sure you press the button
the color no we finished the demo did it
start again hello is anyone there
they already finished they said they
liked it I need someone to stop the demo
hello we need to go back we need to get
out of here no no why Billy what the
hell the exit no what happened here what
no what's going on where is everyone
okay I figure where you go down here of
it Chad what the [ __ ] isolation chamber
are the phone the banana what nice
unquiet finally well I suppose we can
both agree that I failed in my yep my
job was to be a teacher and I so badly
wanted to teach you exactly what the
Stanley parable is supposed to be but
but somehow I couldn't yeah well at any
rate I don't know if I care for the
Stanley parable anymore why not hey
think any of this is actually in the
main game no honestly I doubt it would
that even look like no I think I've had
enough of it no more doors
no more demonstrations no more endings
that's the other problem with this game
there's too many bloody endings yeah me
game in so many times doesn't make sense
oh but back at the beginning of the
demonstration now
hmm no concerns about where it was all
gearing no confusion just a blank slate
yes that's what I want a game of
beginnings hey do you remember just a
few minutes ago when we met for the
first time and I showed you the
technology used to make the demo because
I thought there actually was a demo oh
oh we were so naive back yeah you are
how silly and then when we ended up back
in the waiting room even though you'd
already done that before yeah it's also
fresh in my memory there were such
wonderful moments oh and then when we
played the game with the carbon you won
and then we kept wondering and we ended
up in a stairwell somewhere and we just
kept climbing and climbing flight after
flight after flight I thought they would
never end and then we were on some kind
of cat warp I didn't have any idea what
was down there and I just kept going and
we found that elevator and it said
escape on it we talked about it for a
while about how we couldn't possibly
know whether this was really an escape
but but it seemed worth the try at the
very least it would be in a venture so
it got inside
move the elevator out the Narva now we
had some sense that the end was coming
but we couldn't possibly know when and
then after so long it finally stopped
and we stepped out into the blush of
doors the trees the wildlife the Sun
rising on a new and glorious path
freedom we were free there was nothing
to think nothing to know simply us being
right there in that moment wasn't it so
beautiful
wasn't that moment so singularly
piercingly beautiful we were free
God Danny what the fun we're back in the
Sally parable hands down best demo I
have ever played can't wait for the game
can't [ __ ] wait it's so soon
October 17 that's awesome yeah okay
awesome
and it just [ __ ] closes up hope you
enjoyed watching maybe like if you did
hit subscribe come with me I'll see you
in the next one can't wait for this game
to come on everybody it's not working
what happened to the game I don't
understand the red though he said the
red gardening